absurd censorship sinking its fangs into
more iconic children's books that's
Vivid writing the publisher of Classics
like Matilda and Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory is now scrubbing all
of Roald Dahl's books with a woke eye to
make them quote more inclusive for
example the tiny men in Charlton
Chocolate Factory are now the little
people
I'm for that I'm offended I don't
remember it with the tiny men Oompa
Loompas is that separate no oh that's
separate separate okay James the giant
peach will change his face white with
horror to a Gog with horror what does a
Gog mean when you're shocked like
yeah and a principle a mistrunchable in
Matilda will no longer have a great
horsey face she just has a face that's
so stupid Oh my God
uh okay Jessica this one's perfect for
you to start yes uh they had reportedly
at the Publishers office hired quote
unquote sensitivity readers to go
through the inventory I would like for
you to please define for me a
sensitivity reader
it's someone that I guess covers your
butt if there's one random lawsuit of a
lawsuit that we're a litigious Society I
always think this goes back to the
McDonald's hot coffee right that you
someone's gonna want five million
dollars if your coffee's too hot
um it's also though it's Puffin books in
collaboration with the Roald Dahl story
company so this is his own family that
wants this done and I mean I'm a big fan
of the role doll books I think that you
do need to
if you have mean characters like Miss
Trunchbull was the meanest if you don't
know that she's mean because you're
stripping away the mean words then you
kind of don't have a North star for
these things and Roald Dahl a lot to
criticize him for he was a noted
anti-semite he admitted that he was
totally anti-semitic right before he
died his families apologized profusely
but these changes seem like nothing
changed
like there's no point in doing them
do you think they were worried that
somebody with a horsey face was going to
swim or the words horsey face I think
that that is they change it to bees that
she just has a face every person has a
face so that is really done and what
Roald Dahl was very good at was the way
he wrote gave the children a way to
imagine what he was saying so they also
changed um fat to to enormous I actually
think that might be worse like how is
that how was that better so I think
these people are
um they're taking a valuable space where
other workers should be at Puffin or if
you have to have a college degree Greg
to be a sensitivity reader because you
got to be up on it it changes by the
hour exactly exactly God what a what a
scam I have an idea for a children's
group book it's called offensive Ollie
and he's a little character and all he
does in the children's book is say the
most disgusting things it's the best and
then and then and then you find out at
the end that it's actually a secret
Elixir that makes you live longer and
happier when you hear offensive things
because it builds up your immune system
against really bad things and the kids
are like I don't know why but ever since
I became friends with offense of Ali I
do better in everything the good news
about this story is we're seeing kind of
a mocking reaction on every side about
this this isn't something where it's
just like you know one group of people
going oh my God the other people are
going hahaha everybody's going wow this
is really stupid and I do think that
we're out of time now where woke has now
become the common enemy uh for all of us
not just the rights uh the righties it's
like at the left like everybody's going
like boy this is just hilarious these
people are stupid I think it right now
if we see it if you're a writer this
should disgust you yeah the fact that
when you die you're writing no you
should have a contract a clause in your
contract that says no woke person will
ever touch my right yeah you do yeah
music catalogs everything they go back
and edit people's work they've already
done it judge okay you know that you're
talking about lawsuits right let me
explain you something there will be no
lawsuits because in order to have
standing in the lawsuit you have to
admit that you're fat or that you have a
horse face and you were there protecting
the rights of people with horsey faces
or the rights of fat people otherwise
you have no standing so don't worry
about that this is all nonsense kids
need a colorful that you know they need
a colorful description of what's being
talked about and I think in the end in
some of these books they really when
they talk about something who's mean or
ugly or whatever they're talking not
just about the physical characteristics
but about the the person themselves and
their you know their emotional being as
a mean person too okay I take back the
lawsuit thing
do waste the ammo and things that matter
like in Dr Seuss how many anti-asian
cartoons right we can all look at that
and say oh those are pretty racist
cartoons I understand updates to things
like this more than taking away you know
it's interesting though for a lot of
people they never would have noticed it
until it was pointed out to them and
what favor are you doing when you when
you tell kids things that they're not
ready for but
but a lot of Asian
s would
hey this is a I would like to invest in
a fence of Ollie yes I would like it to
be published tomorrow look like well I
don't know yet he's enormous I would say
he would be short uh incredibly good
looking
I don't know I see where we're headed
here hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade
I want your favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now